nous sommes au assailli le service des
archives intermédiaires du département
de la réunion les agents cherchent ici
les documents produits est reçu par tous
les services de la collectivité
aujourd'hui c'est un versement de la
direction de l'habitat que les
archivistes vont contrôler avant de
l'indexer et l'archivé dans ses
linéaires sur le banc de redorer
vachement bien tout simplement d une
page de garde sur lequel il ya le nom de
la direction du service versant le
nombre de boîtes et on a une typologie
sommaire donc résumons effectivement le
contenu des différentes boîtes la liste
des documents qui composent
effectivement ce versement est levé a
small beau redressement doit être signé
en original par le service versant les
fiches constitutive de ce bordereau de
versement seront ensuite numérisé des
mots-clés décote permettront d'indexer
ces informations aux archives
intermédiaires on a 1 4 km linéaires de
documents vous imagine bien le travail
nécessaire et la rigueur nécessaires
pour l'indexation de tous ces documents
d'ailleurs c'est pour cela que dès qu'un
service nous appelle nous essayons de
répondre plus vite possible voire même
dans la journée une autre mission de ce
service est de rendre disponibles ses
archives sur demande des directions
l'archivage prend ici tout son sens car
il permet une recherche plus rapide et
plus précise des informations en fait
nous faisons ces recherches là puisque
services sont très demandeurs donc notre
but est de retrouver assez vite des
documents puisqu'il ya souvent des
urgences pourront plus et communiquer
très vite au service l'importance de la
conservation des documents
c'est que chaque dossier une fois que le
service en a plus besoin et grèves et de
droits juridiques qui courent sur des
délais différents et tant qu'un dossier
et grévé d'un droit juridique il doit
être impérativement conserver dans les
services de la collectivité
une fois la durée juridique de
conservation expiré les documents seront
soit détruit ou bien s'ils présentent un
intérêt historique et patrimonial ils
seront transmis aux archives
départementales
nous sommes ici dans l'ouest au centre
de tri en charge de la destruction des
documents administratifs de la
collectivité
chaque année c'est près de 15 tonnes de
papier qui sont ainsi valorisés dans une
démarche de développement durable porté
par le département
les documents confidentiels du
département sont implantées sur le site
pour y être broyés puisqu'elle que des
documents confidentiels
ces documents sont ensuite
compact et est mise en balle pour y être
exportées et recyclés en a l'air sur
l'ensemble des données gérées par le
service des archives intermédiaires
seuls 10 à 15% des documents seront
transmis aux archives départementales
sur le quai de déchargement
les archivistes transmette les dossiers
aux agents des archives
nous en avons pris aujourd'hui six
versements qui comprennent 19 boite ça
concerne le service des bourses de la
logistique du laboratoire vétérinaire ce
bordereau il va servir de savoir combien
de boîtes d du service
est arrivé aux archives et on identifie
les boîtes en y mettant des numéros est
en eux en mettant ce qu'il ya dans les
boîtes ce à dire que ces timbres d'euros
si j'ai 50 boîtes je veux savoir qu'est
ce qu'il ya dans la boîte numéro 50
je regarde sur mombreux d'euros et je
verrai par exemple que c'était
décentralisation les projets de loi 2
une fois placé aux archives
départementales
ces informations seront consultables par
le grand public
ces documents conservent leur intérêt
administratif et prennent désormais un
intérêt historique et documents qui sont
ici vont acquérir une valeur
patrimoniale et vont permettre de
replacer des problèmes sur le temps long
je prends deux exemples de recherches
récentes
un chercheur par exemple qui
s'intéressent à la route du littoral
un autre qui s'intéressent au vert blanc
et qui vont permettre à travers ces
documents il va pouvoir retracer les
différentes réponses qui ont été
apportées à cette question au fil des
années afin d'éclairer le la politique
d'aujourd'hui donc les archives
intermédiaires versent régulièrement aux
archives départementales de la réunion
les documents qui ont une valeur
historique et qui vont permettre à tout
citoyen aux chercheurs aux historiens
aux étudiants de mieux connaître
l'histoire de la réunion au travers de
tous ces documents produits par le
conseil général
c'est l'action du conseil général au fil
des années qui permet d'être accessible
à tous le service des archives
intermédiaires permet donc une gestion
ordonnée des informations de la
collectivité
il est également initiateur de la
conservation des documents historiques
du département une valeur patrimoniale
mais toutes ces missions ne pourrait se
faire sans une participation active des
autres services
un travail de formation et de
coordination est menée auprès des agents
de la collectivité
ce travail fait
avec une première séquence de formation
d'un certain nombre d'agents qui ont eux
mêmes être formateur à leur tour c'est
un double intérêt d'une part pour le
service des archives intermédiaires
puisque ça leur permet de respecter une
procédure claire et précise dans leur
travail ultérieur l'archivage mais ça
aussi en intérêt pour la direction en
termes de gestion de bases de données et
notamment de sa gestion papier de la
base de données puisque derrière on a
aussi en respectant cette nomenclature
en fait une lecture et de mise à
disposition d'informations qui est
beaucoup plus simple et rapide